The truth is that motion has two components--it has a horizontal and a vertical component--
and those two components are completely independent.
What do I mean by independent?
I mean that we can break a two dimensional motion problem
into two separate one dimensional motion problem and this is an amazing tool.
Then we go on and shown how in 1 dimension, if we're for example dropping a ball,
at the instant when we dropped the ball, well it has no velocity not quite yet.
One second later, it's picked up some velocity.
It picks up that much again in the 2nd second and again it picks up the same amount in the 3rd,
and we can represent that pictorially with pictures like these.
Now what if instead of dropping the ball, we throw it to the side.
What kind of errors are we going to draw now?
The instance the ball was released, it only has horizontal velocity--that's from you throwing it.
I said before that these components are completely independent so that means after 1 second
this horizontal component--well, it doesn't change.
It keeps going to the right and just like in the 1 dimensional problem before
it picks some speed going downwards.
In fact, it picks up the same amount of vertical speed that it would have
had we just dropped the ball.
After 2 seconds, horizontal component does not change but the vertical looks twice as long
and after 3 seconds the vertical grows again and the horizontal stays the same.
Now this is sort of a strange picture here.
Is this ball moving to the right or is it moving down or is it moving in some other direction?
Which of these errors best describes the direction of the balls' motion at this point in time?
And it's a guess so don't worry if you're wrong.